[Music]
I was 14 years old on some dreary
winter's day in Ireland a friend of mine
brought over a copy of Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 2 on the PlayStation 1 we had an
absolute blast who played skate and
graffiti tag until that night and of
course it was raining outside as it
tends to do quite a lot of the time in
Ireland during the winter but it didn't
matter to us because we were having fun
learning new tricks and exploring parts
of the world we never been to before it
rains a lot in Ireland so our most
popular sports tend to be ones where you
can get wet football hurling rugby
athletics so despite having a healthy
surfing community skateboarding has
never really caught on by the time
spring came along I was signing to see
skaters all over my hometown and after
six months of thinkin Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater myself I'd saved up enough of my
pocket money to buy my first deck a cool
toy machine with some sick boy out
trucks suddenly I was noticing the
height of handrails I'd used all my life
I was saving a pocket money for faster
bearings the music and my headphones was
a Californian soundtrack of pumpkin hip
hop and when a rain door was too dark to
skate I'd go home
escape Venice Beach is rodney mullen for
me and countless other skaters around
the world the Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
franchise was a gateway drug into a
lifestyle and culture that existed
thousands of miles away so how did this
happen was it intentional and could it
happen again well I guess the only way
we could find out for sure if we talk to
them on themselves
[Music]
okay quick history lesson Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater first burst onto the scene in
1999 third been skateboarding games
before but none had captured the culture
of skating anything like thps also the
culture of skating had evolved
popularized in the 60s and 70s
skateboarding had taken a nosedive in
following in the late 80s but had risen
again by the mid 90s the popularity of
the sport has always had peaks and
valleys but the release of thps
coincided with a massive global
expansion of skating kids in countries
around the world were picking up decks
listening to punk music and find baggy
er pants all the while the game series
growing in popularity thps2 is a
sensation 3 the fourth ever 10 at a 10
on gamespot comm and while the
popularity of this series went through
its own peaks and valleys it's still one
of the most beloved sports franchises
in the history of video games at e3 2015
Tony Hawk was on the press junket
publicizing his upcoming Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 5 we talked to him about his
latest game on the game spot III live
stage but hours earlier before the show
had opened Tony was kind enough to sit
down with me and shoot the breeze about
the series I had a lot of questions but
first things first if it wasn't
videogames like me what was it that got
Tony Hawk into skateboarding
my brother was a surfer and he skated at
the time I love the adrenaline of it one
time I was watching him skate and it
just looks so fun and and I picked up
his old board and just started doing it
and realized like this is
you know like I could get into this for
sure and some of my friends were doing
at the time but but I I dabbled a bit
and then when I first saw a skate park
and I saw people literally flying out of
swimming pools that's when I knew I
wanted to do it like I want to do that I
want to have that feeling at any cost
and I wasn't scared to get hurt to to
achieve that and so that was when I was
hooked was when I first moved the
skateboard I loved her first okay pretty
much yeah well at the time I mean it's
it's hard to explain to kids these days
but at the time skateboarding neither
skated pools empty swimming pools or you
skated freestyle and freestyle was
handstands and 360s and it was more
considered the the lame aspect of
skating it was it was like you were
dancing you know and definitely so much
of skating's evolution came from
freestyle tricks but at the time it just
was not the cool way to skate luckily I
I progressed fast when I was young so
when I turned pro at age 14 that may
seem monumental it just meant that you
check the pro box on the entry form of
the competition instead of the amateur
boxing it really was that a few free
t-shirts every now and again an attack
yeah pretty much and and well the option
that maybe they'll make a skateboard
with your name on it and you'll get
maybe fifty dollars a month for that so
I wasn't considering in a career I was
14 at the time I was still in school
obviously as as skating started to
progress and get more popular then there
wasn't a legitimate living to be made
from
it was never the reason we got into it
was it wasn't even an option we got into
it and so it was more like oh that was
that's fun but but it felt very
short-lived and it was in the 80s you
know I was making really good money
until I was maybe 20 and then everything
dropped off immediately Paul could learn
firsthand that doing skateboarding
full-time wasn't going to be easy and
while some skaters weren't interested in
catapulting skating into the mainstream
for Tony legitimizing his favorite sport
was an important goal to ensuring its
longevity but going down the
professional athelete route wasn't
without its pitfalls luckily I lived
through the 80s and I learned a lot of
lessons through that and there was no
YouTube yeah so you know I got I got
away with being cheesy for the most part
but yeah there was definitely I I signed
my name away to some some different
companies and realized that they didn't
care about the integrity of my name or
the integrity of the products for the
most part they just wanted to make money
and and so I paid the price in a lot of
ways just in terms of quality control
and but like I said luckily I I lived
through those years and got a second
chance at it and when I got a second
chance at it I always had final approval
over any product over anything with my
image and I had to fight for that I mean
even had to fight for that through the
thps series I've got so many questions
to ask you about the series first of all
there's this one adding though that I've
been dying to ask you about I heard that
you were trying to like make ends meet
you were doing some video editing work I
was yes I did you think to some trailers
for turbo graphics I did yeah yeah my
friend one of our pro skaters at the
time Jeremy Klein was I mean that's how
that's how rough it was to be a pro
skater he was working at turbo graphics
Wow because he's a video game fanatic
and really understands what it takes to
make a good game so turbo graphics hired
him I had a video editing system that I
was doing stuff through skate companies
like tapes
oh yeah three it was my my some of the
time was to s-vhs decks running through
a video toaster into a third s-vhs tech
that was that was it they are state of
the art yeah I was thankful that they
allowed me to do it and you know
obviously I came to I came in with
within their budget I I want to say it
was just for the system for the most
part but I think there were a couple
games they were highlighting but we were
pretty renegade like we were
interviewing video game retailers and
asking them to talk about other
games you know you mean like we just
didn't really care cuz like you know we
wanted to be authentic what a skating
grew in popularity in the mid 90s Tony
and a host of other skaters started to
get more Pro work the number of
competition is increased skate companies
were expanding again kids rewind tapes
and Dex snapping their trucks the media
ran skating was also expanding it was
bleeding into music film and wider
culture and Tony aware of the video game
world started to shop around an idea he
had for a video game he just needed the
right partner who knew the right partner
would end up being Bruce Willis and we
went and pitched the idea to all kinds
of software companies and none of them
bit in fact some of them were less
friendly about telling us how
skateboarding would never be a popular
video again
Midway but but but the seed was planted
that I was interested in doing again and
when Activision called me and said hey
we heard you want to do a game we we are
working on an inch and please come up
and see it I went and met them and saw
this engine that just felt intuitive it
felt like there's so much it could could
be expanded on and it was he was Bruce
Willis in like this combat outfit
skating through this wasteland but but
the engine was was on point because they
had used the engine that they had built
for apocalypse to run skating and
apocalypse didn't do well but I knew
that we with my it you know with my
connections and my influence and my
experience we can make something really
special and I signed up almost
immediately what was your involvement
then with the project because one of the
things that comes across with the Tony
Hawk's games is the legitimacy of them
that there's something so pure it almost
feels like they were made by like this
sort of elder counsel of skateboard it
was very much I mean I was for the first
you know the development process was
about two and a half years and I
embedded myself with Neversoft
I really wanted that I wanted to feel
authentic I wanted the game to be
something skaters to be proud of that
that was my goal all along I didn't
think that it would create a genre of
video games I didn't think that it was
going to inspire thousands of kids to go
try skateboarding I just wanted a video
game that I could show to other other
experienced skaters and they were good
like oh that is cool that feels real you
know and that's that was the the end
goal for it and so I was very very
involved in every step of the way and I
had to give Neversoft a crash course and
you know what is acceptable in skating
what what is cool and and they got it
you know and they were very receptive to
it when did you start realizing that you
were getting people to play to buy
skateboards who were playing this game
kids who might mean necessarily who
never got in touch with football and or
soccer or hockey um I think after the
second game really
is when I realized we you know we
created something special and something
that was far beyond my wildest
expectations I knew we had something
special
in the beginning when my escaped friends
who also played games just started
calling it the game that was it I mean
in the skate industry it was like have
you played the game and I knew that if
they had such reverence for it already
that we we had something there was a
perfect storm of excitement for skating
you know some of it started through the
X Games definitely a lot of it through
our video game but but it was just that
it was the time kids wanted something
new they I think they were jaded with
with mainstream ball sports and the
superstars of those who weren't even in
touch with reality anymore you know they
like they just don't they don't interact
with the fans they know you know and
they felt like some other I don't know
it's just something intangible and I
think that when they saw skating
especially on TV at the time they saw
these these people who were passionate
who were risking their lives just for
the sake of progression for nothing else
you know no fame no fortune and they
they appreciated that and they
appreciated the adrenaline rush the
instant gratification you got from it
the sort of self motivation that comes
out of it the challenges you can create
I don't know I just felt like it was the
right time for a generation that was
that was pining for something exciting
yeah
well Mia what's going on it down I'm
pretty good good to have you here in
beautiful San Francisco yeah just let me
hear and you're here one of your
favorite skate spots I am oh
sorry
yeah no you can really go oh okay
this is one of these really like
pathetic situations where I'm really
excited about something that no one
cares about because I spent way too long
in my life playing this in Tony Hawk's
one now I'm here I get just as excited
about this as I do as someone gets about
Alcatraz which is really sad well you
get here and then it's it's actually not
hearing no it's gone they got rid of a
back in the nineties sad I'm just sad
for no reason about something my house
shouldn't have any attachment to I never
got to see it this is my mate Neil from
my hometown of Waterford in the south of
Ireland it's a city of about 40,000
people you know the type of place where
everyone knows each other or at least
knows somebody that you know Neil
started skating one summer in Ireland
but unlike me he never stopped he edited
dozens of videos showing off local
talents and even founded his own local
board company cloud he lives in Canada
now but right as we were putting this
episode of the point together he sent me
a message saying he was gonna be in San
Francisco so we've met at EMB one of the
most infamous spots in skateboarding's
heyday or at least what's left of it
[Music]
that got me into this game I liked
skating
growing up like but I could never reach
it because we came from such a small
little city where that was completely
unattainable so like when that came in
it like taught me all the tricks we
should make up names herself like years
ago like people around my area be like
oh I used to call that the Manila and
then I figured out that it was called
the ollie like so and that was around
the boom like Tony Hawk's created that
whole thing every random person that
you've ever met back home you used to
skate they're like hey give me a go down
there like I used to skate and they're
like do the Tony Hawk like it people
don't realize how much of an impact that
had on like everywhere like that huge
it's scary minded the most dangerous
people you'll ever see in your life back
home as we're walking down the street
you're like oh I have to cross over
this guy's gonna try to mug me
and he's like hey give me your
skateboard and you can actually do like
a pop shuvit or a kickflip cuz once in
his life skateboard and touched him and
changed him for a small amount of time
and then the rest of life just crushed
him and brought him back on track to be
just to follow his destiny have not ever
been a scare like so many people who
play video games are like huge because
he just it's just a way to escape into
another world and so yeah I don't know
the same for me I'm just really nerdy
though the original Tony Hawk game like
first and second one and maybe the Tori
had a turtle that's amazing like the
three of those I'm part of that
generation I guess like well it was
raining outside we didn't have indoor
skate parks we had not enjoyed just
that's it just with your house and you
just sit there and you just play that
religiously every day and you know every
song that comes on and it's burned into
your brain even if you didn't like the
song you have to just do you're in the
middle of trying to figure stuff out
i hand-picked all the skaters from the
first game yeah and the music I was
heavily involved in because I wanted to
represent skate lifestyle and skate
culture and I really wanted to represent
and well I did like I said I never
thought it was gonna be something that
would resonate beyond the skate world
and inspire skaters to go and buy
Playstations no no I've only played five
games ever in my whole life and I play
him so much it's so sad everybody takes
the piss out of me I think it's like
play scape Tony Hawk's Forza Gran
Turismo and GTA and that's it I don't
play anything else by th ps3 the Tony
Hawk's franchise had established itself
as a powerhouse but with that type of
popularity comes a problem how do you
innovate an idea that's already working
never stops first idea was to expand
into wider skate culture when you look
back at the tow games what is your sort
of your biggest takeaway in terms of
their identity within your franchise um
well I enjoyed that we took a different
direction and did more of a story based
mode of play and so I I really enjoyed
that I love Bam's influence on it you
know I love that it did have that
irreverent jackass element to it and I'm
very proud of that series it was
definitely departure from the thps
series but but it established us as
doing something new and innovative see
HBS has always been an annualised
franchise but over the coming years the
audience was starting to get exhausted
underground to command 2004 American
wasteland the no 5 followed by project a
1006 and proving grounds in 2007 that
year also saw the rise of a competitor
the fantastic skate series which took
the open world skate culture and fused
nature of thps but leaned more heavily
into the pseudo simulator of project
dates nailed the trick mechanic I asked
Tony what he thought of his biggest
competitor yeah well it was inevitable
that other people gonna make games and
some tried in the past but they mostly
copied our control schemes so no one
really bit so the idea that they came up
with something that was absolutely a new
way to control a skater was interesting
you know and and it also showed how far
skating had come
the idea that two giant publishers would
create successful video games is amazing
to me it was a bummer just because it's
sort of it's sort of diluted both series
and eventually they both came to an end
I had that look in that era and I was
about to get worse a skateboarding on
the series struggled to retain
mainstream appeal caulk and Activision
looked towards the motion-control market
for an answer would ride and shred in
within the video game world are sort of
like looked at as this like sort of a
goofy attempt to reconstruct a franchise
yeah well I was more for me the idea to
a ride was more based on the success of
Guitar Hero and at Fir if role based
games to be honest shred was more what I
had in mind when we set out to do ride
the control mechanics of it was more it
was more fine-tuned and we added snow
morning so I really I enjoyed tread but
by the time shred came out people had
moved past peripherals yeah and so it
was just for me for me was bad timing
and people still think like you're you
know you're insane for defending those
games but I really do believe that shred
was was where we were trying to land did
you ever see the video of the guy who
took some trucks and drilled them into
my board I did see that yeah that's a
friend of mine neal qiime so that
happened in in my hometown Waterford
where we were all that skateboarding did
you guys have her attempt to do that no
but I was impressed that he did it but
through the 2000 but I'm perfectly good
peripheral someone gave it to me
actually I can't really take full credit
for it you know Aero die you still work
in spokes he just goes I have this
someone gave me other games up like you
got to do something with it and then we
just sat around and then me and Dean
will write off we should just skate this
realistically so it's our drilling stuff
into it and then before we knew it then
everyone did so much good stuff on a
tool which I couldn't believe it all the
comments are just kids just hating us so
much you guys are rich you
this it's like it's completely the
opposite everything in it is broken that
we got for free but a pool is crap as
people ever like and they were just like
if I had that laptop cuz we smash a
bunch of laptops in the ground and stuff
but they're all dead anyway and people
just hate it on it but then it didn't
most people love that side
it's cool I didn't think it would end up
being that famous like he still skates
to this day he does yeah thanks for
thanks for bringing our virtual game
into reality yeah thanks for bridging
that gap finally that's what he said to
the cops when this I saw that yeah
that's just a video game on Facebook see
the bonds on orbit dude don't be go the
walk winner
Your Honor this is real life which means
I see a job what kind of thing this is
only mock it's not even real look suck
up stop pawns on likes on your video
game xbox regular to pack up do jokes
Boxster
if you watch the point frequently than
you know the one of the things that
fascinates me the most are the times
that video games impact on our
real-world lives and though digital
worlds on the real world that we live in
are two very distinct separate things
there are times times like this where
the barriers between the two seem to
fade a little Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
inspired myself Neil and hundreds of
thousands perhaps even millions of other
skaters to pick up decks in real life as
myself and Neil sat there at EMB one of
the most infamous spots in Street
skating history we were struck by
another reality
skateboarding's popularity waxed and
waned over the years and with the burst
and global recognition that came with
the thps games arrived a new breed of
skateboarding family friendly safe
rounded off Neil still skates to this
day but Embarcadero is no longer the
spot it used to be the bowls and gaps
were bulldozed over years ago now it's a
Plaza where rich professionals have
lunch today there's some sort of Fun Run
being held with a bunch of financial
companies not only that the entire
city's been capped skate blockers are
everywhere cops are already looking at
us as we're doing this interview we've
just sat down for a chat this is it
we're sitting at EMV I never thought I'd
be here doing something like this it's
really funny is it like it's like the
kind of depressing that would be the
only way you're ever gonna be able to
escape this bar game Tony oh yeah it's
so much progression so much happen here
there was like this weird crew and they
had a mayor and less hierarchy and this
crazy thing where if you showed up and I
didn't like it they would get
rid of it and we right here just casual
is like hey but like 10 years ago we
couldn't do this they'd be like what are
you guys doing get out of here and it
beat the out of us like
that's kind of cool though I like that
skating has that weird that doesn't
exist the most I mean it's it's reached
a point now where like they've made
power-ups like all the parrots are just
fabricate versions walk these walls like
they made this point accident and like
the streets getting involved with this I
know the skate parks are mimicking what
this was and the original stuff is gone
so the next generations won't have those
weird streets boss so like I'm in the
skate park and this is perfectly
fabricated farming we've pushed
everything into this condensed little
almost football pitch where it was
boiled on the streets and now it's just
like in a box with lights and perfect
ground
I don't that's a little bit sad like
yeah is there anything like just this
and the trees they are over there it's
just those steps that are like the most
infamous trees they are probably from
the 90s maybe I think so anyway all
that's left of the heyday of EMB is this
spot stuck in behind some financial
firms funrun tent you need a skater's
eye to spot it but here lies the marks
of hundreds of thousands of failed
kickflips and shove it this stair set
the levels in Tony Hawk's one and four
are all that's left of EMB we saw here
Illinois and just like drank and just
talked about how influential and
hilarious and important this little area
was to all that history
history and that's the reason why it was
in Tony Hawk's and I gave it in the back
of it tents
yes I'm just saying the same thing and
they're wondering what are we doing what
are these idiots pointing at the ground
what's wrong with these people
especially this guy it's all somewhere
you could stay right here heading up
here seven over there like it's kind of
still there so this is the core of why
Tony Hawk is such a divisive figure in
the world of skating the game's spread
this niche sport far and wide but it did
come at a cost
mainstream recognition has forever
changed the face of skating the digital
worlds of Tony Hawk have forever changed
their real-world counterparts this
responsibility seems to weigh heavy on
Tony's shoulders so I asked him does he
want to be remembered I mean above all
else I want to be remembered as as an
innovative skater that's always been my
drive and still is to this day I'm still
trying to learn new stuff I'm still
trying to you know make videos and be
contemporary you know I would like to
think that I to raise awareness for
skating and to possibly make it more
legitimate in the eyes of uninitiated
because skating had a bad rap for a long
time and now it's something that parents
are encouraging the kids to do and if I
had some part of that I'm proud of it
perhaps Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 will
have the widespread appeal of the early
Hall games perhaps it won't but you can
be sure of one thing every day people
around the world are experiencing new
and interesting forms of art media and
culture via the unique power of video
games and some kids somewhere in the
world in America or Brazil or Ireland
will play this game and be inspired to
pick up a deck we think of video game
locations as fake versions of real
places these isolated realities you know
we go and visit there for a time before
we return back to our normal lives but
what if the barriers separating those
two were looser than we thought for
gamers my age Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
will go down as one of the most
important games of our generation but on
top of that it's also a reminder of just
how powerful games can be games have the
ability to inspire us to try new things
that change what makes us happy even to
reshape architecture itself it's a
reminder that games like any other form
of art are capable of impacting our
lives and influencing the type of people
[Music]
you
[Applause]